c'est quelque chose il ya peu
d'émissions comme ça qu'ils vieillissent
aussi bien il ya plein d'émissions sur
m6 que je critique celle là je la d'or
parce que tout est parfait lui est
parfait il incarne la personne parfaite
on peut pas le changer et chaque
histoire quoi que tu dises quand tu
rentres dedans tu vas au bout c'est très
bien scénarisé je m'en fous si parfois
c'est impeut truqués ou pas on en a
parlé peu importe c'est extrêmement bien
fait et j'adore cette émission axée rare
que je me tue tête si ça va calmer vos
hits m6 soit 2 2 oui moi je suis plus
peiné que linguine mais moi je suis
toujours la même le même schéma
mécanique de l'émission séjour il a
river c'est l'effarement toutes les
émissions
après c'est énervement arrondi
compassion et après la fin ces
affections ça c'est toujours la même
chose
c'est trop clément puisque l'équipe rue
du défriché le terrain c'est normal
avant nos klein comme par hasard il met
tout de suite le doigt là où ça fait mal
à ça que sur ses surgelés
comme par hasard il arrivé depuis deux
minutes tout est comme ça monsieur
ces trucs et scénarisé sous gordon
ramsay il est même flux cuisinier il est
conseiller conjugal mais pour qui on
suit là c'est pas pascal le grand frère
il faut le virer très vite cette
émission ne pas être renouvelés il faut
l'éliminer
ce qui porte sa et me disent oui
meilleure émission de coaching
ever en plus qu'à fin psychologue
édition est beaucoup plus profonde qu'on
ne le pense c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de psychologie mais il est à
fond là-dedans et en plus ça ce que
j'aime c'est qu'il ya un accompagnement
psychologique industriel avec les
différents kiosques
qu'est-ce qui a question rencontre des
gens géniaux et l'autre ça y est parti
très loin et s'est pris pour un député
sur je rencontre des gens en effet quand
vous étiez au pouvoir
non c'est bon rouleur il atteindre les
attelles les attachés de presse à oui si
tu pleures ce qu'en pensent ses
téléspectateurs beynat une personne vous
a donné la parole mais c'est sympa quand
même
l'émission doit-elle se renouveler à 55
% oui et non à 40 heures ils sont plutôt
d'accord donc avec jean-michel et
monsieur que je ne connais pas j'ai un
petit mac compte un petit dessert avant
d'initier ou avoue juste vous c'est
votre émission préférée principalement
hyper intéressant et je ne pense pas que
les gens jouent parce que tout le monde
en veut un acteur donc c'est dire que ça
se verrait donc moi j'adore vraiment ça
vachement touchant et intéressant